um as your theory gets to be more known
and like through the media and in the
culture in the next 10 or 15 years and
these things start
it starts spitting up more and more and
people come to understand it more um do
you think you're gonna become become an
object like a messianic adoration or
anything
no i don't think so
i don't think so because um
[Music]
it's gonna
start proving itself true as people get
to know it more me as you get closer
well yes but see it's i mean i'm glad
you mentioned this it always comes up in
some context my bit
makes no
sense
and is useless unless i'm completely
ordinary
in other words it's all very fine
einstein and these characters who break
through to these places but what i'm
saying
is that this is for plain folks
and uh
no he said i am the light
you don't hear me saying crap like that
no no i am not the light
what psychedelics are doing is
empowering us to get rid of gurus we
don't need these guys uh nobody is
special that what the mushroom says i
love it it says for one human being to
seek enlightenment from another is for
is the equivalent of one grain of sand
on a beach seeking enlightenment from
another
in other words
human beings are so much alike that it
just doesn't matter
i am so much like mother teresa that it
doesn't matter you are so much like the
dalai lama that to make distinctions is
pointless i mean why bother he just has
a better job that's all we're all in it
together nobody has a leg up and that's
another thing the mushroom said you know
the generous
position
is to say
well you know all these religions they
all have a piece of the action
everybody's got a little bit of the
action you know what the mushroom says
nobody's got a piece of the action
it's all wrong
wrong wrong wrong dead wrong not even
warm
and and that's like this seeking
enlightenment thing no we're there's
only one person
you know and that's this human person
and we are the cells of that human
person and and we entertain the notion
of separateness but we come out of the
same dirt and we go back into the same
dirt
no
we are transcending messiahs it's not
necessary the whole notion of
psychedelics is that we can each become
our own messiah you go in there you
contact the logos
you contact the logos you don't get it
boiled down
from some priest
you know
if a theory like this were vindicated i
suppose i would be hailed as a
mighty smart fella
but that's all
that's all it's about
[Music]
you